obviously anyone's still breathing in
the final season of Game of Thrones it's
going to have a pretty huge impact on
the story but one man Sandor Clegane
might end up being a little more than
just another tough guy with a sword this
is why the Hound might be more important
than you realized one of the reasons the
Hound has become such a fan favorite
over the years is that he's eminently
relatable in a world of dragons ice
zombies and a Machiavellian sociopaths
the only thing he really believes in is
himself and his sword but as the show
was ramped up its fantasy tropes from
the relatively grounded early episodes
the hounds continuing atheism has become
more and more of an important plot
points after his near-death experience
at the hands of Brienne in season four
The Hound recuperated under the watchful
eye of brother Rey robbing people to
stop killing people start helping people
never too late come back shortly after
Rey is brutally killed by roving members
of the Brotherhood without banners
because it is Game of Thrones after all
still the hounds brief connection with
the man seems to have been setting up an
about-face for the amoral swordsman
after all it's only after Ray's death
that the Hound gets involved with the
unkillable zealots beric Dondarrion
which leads him into the path of the
night King and his unstoppable zombie
army with rage religious teachings fresh
in his mind the show is primed us for a
powerful moment when the Hound realizes
there are things bigger than him in the
world and no we're not just talking
about this guy between the books a
television show and the many many fan
theories swirling around the plot and
his characters you'd be forgiven for
losing track of some of the various
prophecies floating about on the Game of
Thrones universe still there's at least
one that you should definitely be
thinking about before the final season
hits that would be the prophecy that
concerns a Zora hi or the prince that
was promised the basic gist is that azor
Ahai was a legendary swordsman he was
able to forge a sword so powerful that
it would routinely burst into flames
this hero eventually fought against
undefeated a terrible darkness that
threatened the entire world just about
every character on the show has been
theorized to be azor Ahai reborn
although Jon Snow and Daenerys are two
of the fan favorites by a mile
however it also could be possible that
the Hound is a
ah hi the main crux of the theory is
that it would be poetic for the hound a
man who believes in nothing and has a
paralyzing fear of fire to wield a holy
flaming blade against the night king in
a grand show of selflessness while it
might be a bit of a stretch to suggest
that the Hound is reborn the ability his
relationship to the current welder of a
flaming sword
berrak definitely gives this theory some
credence the two have a long history and
if Barrack were to actually die for good
it would only be fitting for the Hound
to pick up his flaming sword in battle
okay so that's a good chance that the
Hound isn't actually the fabled prince
that was promised in fact that would be
a pretty late and unexpected twist for a
show that's generally been adept at
setting up its plot points before they
unfold still it's almost certain that
the Hound will resolve his phobia of
fire and there's good reason to believe
he'll do so by picking up barracks
flaming sword as fans of Game of Thrones
will know the Hound has a deathly fear
of fire that began after a childhood
encounter with his older brother it was
just like you said a while back pressed
me to the fire like I was a nice juicy
mutton chop it's character-building 101
for a character to overcome trauma over
the course of their arc and the hounds
are long overdue for some flame base
exposure therapy and they can only help
that there's already a God in the world
of Game of Thrones of something of a
penchant for fire it was already been in
contact with the Hound the dead and
marching past
thousands of them a number of other
characters in the show of express their
faith in the Lord of lights but the
hound is the first non follower we've
seen receive a vision from the God
it all adds up to the near certainty
that a Lord of Light is maneuvering a
man terrified of fire into doing his
divine bidding how poetic
if there's one single thing that Game of
Thrones truly won from this show's final
season it has to be clicking ball a fun
term for a longer weighted battle
between the Hound and his brother Gregor
Clegane the game Bowl has been demanded
doubted and in season seven a seemingly
confirmed it's not how it ends for you
brother you know it's coming for you
you've always known the two brothers
might have had a short-lived duel back
in season one but they've both been
through the wringer since then the
mountain was poisoned by Oberyn Martell
which led to him becoming a mute Essam
be asked slave to Cersei Lannister
meanwhile the helmsman practically all
the way up and down Westeros in search
of purpose but even after everything
they've been through Sandor and Gregor
don't seem to have forgotten their
childhood hatred for each other check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite TV shows are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bail
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]